lieblings gar nichts wir haben uns immer
wieder alle zusammen versammelt hier
mein aufnahme zwar um über jesus zu
sprechen
jesus sollten wir über ihn gesprochen
eine freude das ist natürlich nicht der
grund warum wir hier heute dieses video
angeklickt habe sondern ihr seht es
bereits im titel eingeblendet ich höre
immer wieder dass sie gar nicht
eingeblendet ist anders ich habe euch
mal wieder auf twitter gesagt meine
damen und herren ihr habt die
möglichkeit einige videos einzusenden
unter dem hashtag luca reagiert und
darauf werde ich jetzt reagieren und
filme apres ski richtig fürsorglich mir
immer miteinander umgeht aber meine
damen und herren was habe ich hier schon
zu melden ich habe keine freunde ich
habe keine freundin das medien in dem
video hat allerdings eine freundin und
wie sie mit ihrer freundin umgeht dabei
mir oben im wohnzimmer gerade eine
bekannte von mir schild würde ich sagen
gehe ich mal zu ihr genauso hin und
verhalte mich genauso wie das mädel in
dem video hat super funktioniert warum
schickt man mir so etwas zu erwarten die
leute die mir sowas einsenden dann
irgendwie eine reaktion von mir dass ich
das irgendwie nach mache oder ich
wünsche wieder die ganzen instagram imst
und videos davon
wir sehen die einbindung höfe großes
forever perfektem ich weiß nicht um was
es sich da handelt aber perfekt großes
ja dass wir das jetzt irgendwie so ein
blumenladen die irgendwie eine tolle
neuen trailer allerdings machen wollen
es geht um ein faires spiel ist das
nicht sogar stars table
[Musik]
ich glaube das ist wirklich stars der
freunde ich habe es nur auf einem kanal
mazars der glaube ich zweimal
hochgeladen dann wird mein account
gesperrt weil die meinten ich sei zu alt
für das spiel ich mein okay wenn jetzt
irgend ein zwölfjähriger call of duty
spiel was ab 18 ist dann kann es
natürlich sein dass da jemand kommt und
sagt henke im rauschen du bist jetzt
zwölf so darf das spiel noch gar nicht
spielen aber zu alt sein für ein spiel
was wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen
[Musik]
ja wir haben es mittlerweile verstanden
dass ein star stable trailer ist
es ist
der wirt der immer besser lobt groß ist
meine damen und herren der stars der
beklagen unseres vertrauen denn ich mal
wieder stars spielen sollte werde ich
definitiv nicht in euren klaren gehen
wisst ihr was ich traurig finde ich
hatte früher kunst in der show hatte das
bis ins abi mit genau was ich hatte da
die klausur geschrieben und kein lka
gehabt aber ich hab sich kunst auf jeden
fall eine sehr lange zeit in meiner
schullaufbahn und was wir immer mal hin
und wieder machen mussten waren selbst
porträtzeichnen von uns und abgeben und
dadurch konnte man immer seine noten so
ein bisschen verbessern und wenn ich zu
der zeit schon youtube gemacht hätte und
so viele verzeichnungen bekommen hätte
wäre ich hätte ich hätte eine eins
bekommen kunst stopp stopp stopp ganz
kurz sind das nachos auf der pizza mit
nachos und käse und step und gummibären
und ich muss sich dabei ganz kurz
unterbrechen
mit nachos mit käse okay aber mit sind
mit gummibärchen schokolade hat fährt
den ski hingeschmissen wisst ihr ich hab
ja vor einigen monaten selbst
herausgebracht wir vorne liegt sogar
noch der kartoffel so sei das nämlich
außer dass jedoch der karton vor der
hitze das war eine pizza margherita aber
eine richtig geile italienische pizza
margherita also richtig denn am boden
richtig große pizza auf jeden fall mache
ich mir gerade so gedanken hey wie kommt
man vielleicht die nächste pizza machen
weil die pizza kam ja mega kraft bei
euch an macht da vielleicht irgend wie
salami stückchen drauf oder brüste oder
keine ahnung warum er packt nachos und
schokolade gummibärchen drauf was bist
du für ein mensch apropos videos freund
ich habe mich nur bei euch bedanken uns
war sie wieder in deutschland schnellst
wachsender gaal war warum warum die
abonniert mich einfach bitte von mir das
ist nike reden und approbierte du bist
auf jeden fall geblockt jetzt mal
richtig ist das irgendwie neuer trend
dass michaels kinder beleidigen in
meinem letzten luca reagiert video hat
mich ein fünfjähriges mädchen geht es
kuka du stinkst immer mit den duschen
und jetzt sind es schon zwei kinder als
ich mal guckt euch diese gesichter an
das sind mega süße kinder wieso
beleidige mich wieso ich denke ich mein
ja ja vielleicht
erst mal mega korrekt von dir dass du
werbung für meinen job gemacht hast
freundin findet um werbe video
eingeblendet war schon mal da ist
natürlich super - shop.de ich denke
jeder kennt das wir arbeiten derzeit an
der sommerkollektion
ja da bin ich noch gar nichts diesen
aber es wird natürlich wieder lässt
fragen
die ts inder aus
alter ohne spaß mega korrekt ich bin
wirklich ist variiert auch mega ist von
euch das video mal lieber zu ende luca
okay ich fühle mich gut youtuber wird
diesem heftigen hintergrundlicht einen
donker fällen ja hallo
wie heißt du denn hallo mein name ist
luca parlament mit nico hallo mein name
ist lookout also das ist dass das war in
meinen augen mit eines der beschissen
schauspieler die ich je gesehen habe
da sind wir das ist der mit euch falsch
gelaufen
lucio ist der name von uns allen von den
leuten hier von einer community von den
leuten die meine videos anschauen von
uns allen halt einfach aber längst nicht
so ein ding werden so um egal als
superstar vor der luke schritt jetzt
immer hart
die luxus vielmehr wie soll wenn er wie
wahrscheinlich verkauften bilderrahmen
und er ist auch kein bild drin und wenn
man dann abonnenten von meinem canalis
und wenn der bilderrahmen wenn er das
herz ist dass das befüllt wird mit
energie mit liebe und der bilder bekommt
ein bild bekommen dass das lama bin ich
ich nehme keine drogen wirklich nicht
wieso schickt mir das kann ich auch und
da kommt er an wenn dem luca kisten aus
dem lukas rupp um 120 so dass man gar
nicht mehr so klug da kann ich erst mal
daumen hoch dass der freunde und bei
30.000 likes passiert gar nichts
die richtige meine dampft es endlich
bist hast du noch nie gesehen
hallo was für anleger heißt luca ich
wollte die wohnung sauber machen
frühjahrsputz mega lieb von dir egal ich
habe zwar kein plan wenn du bist aber
ich finde sie es aus wie sonnen dieter
dieses jahres könnten täter seien also
danke für den frühjahrsputz wie vor du
zu mir kommen ist das alles schön und
sauber ist dass du nicht so viel arbeit
hast das ist ja mega liebt dieter ich
wollte mir die nächste woche zu dir
kommen aber ist ja voll geil dass du dir
jetzt schon den frühjahrsputz übernimmst
aber ich krieg den staubsauger sich
nicht an die da du kriegst die
staubsauger nicht anders will ich jetzt
aber mal sehen hier
er hat dem der den zielen geschlossen
was da los ist auch mensch die da komm
ich hälfte war ich sag jetzt mal wie
mein staubsauger an kriegt ein paar
sekunden später sorgte daher selber weil
mein staubsauger geholt jetzt macht ihr
mann ihr tutorial wie du das ding an
krieg sonst waren war friert videos auch
schon was dass ein bisschen drauf und
dann aber gar nicht ganz neuer kraft und
so unnormal von erstmal dritten mal
wieder anhören
so wieder so muss ich dafür jetzt acht
schönheit wir werden es auf eventuelle
werden einige leute dieses nicht so ganz
verstehen und zwar misst oder ein
papagei oder der unterschied ob
stayfriends oder papagei duscht sich und
zwar immer wenn ich im gym war mache ich
danach einen snapple meiner dusche wo
ist mir irgendwie schauen durchs gesicht
lassen
falls ihr diese videos von mir nicht
kennt sollte jemand mal ganz ganz
schnell auf instagram freundlich heißt
du da nämlich laser luca obwohl ich habe
sogar neuen youtube-kanal wo meine
installation service wöchentlich
hochgeladen werden also eventuell auch
danach folgen das war neue youtube kanal
einfach eine suche eingeben oder
beschreibungen lukas tories werden jetzt
wöchentlich meine instagram da ist
deutlich hochgeladen und wenn ich ein
leicht mache zum beispiel morgen mache
ich im livestream am sonntag da wird
dann auch hochgeladen am montag und so
das mega gut also einfach mal da oder
lassen und auch da vielleicht freuen
das zeigt es wirklich wieder die hashtag
lucio dies besser als alles übrigens
danke dass das buch von mir meiner
mutter so mega kreis angekommen das bei
euch wir haben sogar einen award
bekommen media control award meine damen
und herren
ihr könnt mich sogar dadurch sind das
nicht mehr als ein taschenbuch im
dezember 2017 freundin im monat bot das
buch herausgekommen ist haben wir direkt
dieser award gewonnen megageil großes
dankeschön an euch ganz großen applaus
an euch ich habe selber nur ganz wenige
von büchern gekauft
das machen sie ja vom wieder meine damen
und herren mit akkus immer noch mein
staubsauger ein geländer vorne ist ein
müller war komplett ausgegeben wir den
ganzen sachen hier vorne ist ein buch
mit dem wir wollen da meine mutter nicht
das ist ja mega cool oder
ich bin dagegen nicht so cool und hab
aber ich wollte sagen wie ich es habe
ich freunde aber das stimmt auch nicht
[Musik]